hello steve kaufman here i haven't done
this for a little while so it's about
time i guess
uh guess what i'm going to talk about
language learning again all right
um i just finished reading this book
here
which is by sebastian leitner zoe
lentman
how you
learn how to learn and the way to
success
now he doesn't just talk about language
learning he talks about a variety of
subjects
i enjoyed it because it was a chance for
me to refresh my german i read the book
in german i picked out a bunch of words
that i didn't know that i
entered as a list into link where i was
able to review them and so forth
and lightner is sort of one of the
earliest people to propose these
space repetition systems and his system
consisted essentially of of a box
and the box was divided into i think
four or five compartments and so you had
your cards that you were learning things
on and as you got one right you moved it
into the second compartment and then he
went
through that second compartment and
moved it into the third and the fourth
and the fifth
which is a learning system and probably
a very good one i wouldn't have the
patience to prepare all those cards but
i'm sure if you did it it's kind of a
neat way to
to make sure that you're focusing on
those items that you're having trouble
learning problem is when you go through
a list there are certain things that
you'll learn right away that just click
and certain things that no matter how
often you review them they just don't
stick
so he applies this to language learning
the book has a lot of stuff in it about
you know the role of of different
researchers on how the brain learns
things and remembers things and
talks about pavlov's dog and how animals
were trained to behave in certain ways
it reviews
you know the influence of behaviorist
skinner and others on
the development of
learning theory
i must say i didn't end up getting that
much out of the book
some of the things that he says that i
agree with are the idea that the more
meaning that there is in in a word the
more likely you are to remember it so
i mean i remember words when i'm
learning languages
because i i identify them with a phrase
i identify them with a particular
context or perhaps with several contexts
so that
as i rem as i review as i do in link the
different phrases where they occurred
and i'm reminded of those different
episodes
then that seems to help me remember them
but inevitably there are some words that
you just can't remember no matter how
many times you review them
and others this
sometimes relatively unimportant words
that click in right away
um
i can't remember all the stuff that was
in there
yeah i mean you need to invest some time
some time that's why again at link we
recommend that people edit the phrases
that we capture automatically the more
time you invest and try to hide that
sunbeam the more time that you invest in
in an item and thinking about it the
more uh the more likely is it is that
it'll stick yet he contradicts this at
one point he suggests that in in working
with uh flash cards we should also work
with them very quickly so that we get a
almost a split second
uh
time lapse between seeing let's say the
word that we're trying to learn and then
seeing what it means in our language and
i've been doing that a little bit with
link where i've been going through our
flash cards sort of hyper fast
click click click click click click to
to create that visual connection within
a fraction of a second between the word
i'm trying to learn
and the meaning or the hint that i've
put in there
editorially to tell if if that's
effective or not
the uh you know i kind of end up with
where i started and that is that
that the what i most like doing
in language learning is listening and
reading
i really enjoy reading on link because i
can click on words right away and i can
see what they mean and i can put them
into a database for review later on
i like being reminded every now and
again as
now that link we're sending out these um
emails with my saved link so that i can
flash card them that helps remind me
when i i'm busy doing something else and
all of a sudden the email shows up and i
have to go through my flash cards so
that's good but the most enjoyable
activity is listening and reading i've
just
loaded up my uh
my little uh ipod shuffle here
with some kuprin
and i'm about to charge off on a run and
listen to russian and that's kind of the
most fun and there'll be all kinds of
words that i don't know and when i come
back i'll read them on link and and save
them and
so i guess i guess the idea is that that
we can't really treat things that we're
trying to learn as as
sort of neutral
inanimate things that have no meaning
they have meaning
the more meaning they have the better
and the more one of the things that
lightner says which is very true is the
more words you have the more words
you can learn because obviously you know
more of the context the surrounding
context you have more words that are
perhaps similar to the word that you
have saved i know that in russian and in
german if i look at my words
alphabetically i'll see a whole bunch of
words that are obviously related to each
other so you start
even if you don't guess the word right
away
uh when you do look it up and you
remember oh yeah that mean well yeah it
means that because actually it's similar
to this other word so the more words you
have that help connect it the better
one of the reasons we ended up with this
term link for our system is that
language learning is all about linking
you're linking sounds to meaning you're
linking words
to a context you're linking a word to a
phrase to an episode that you remember
you're linking words to other words that
are similar you're creating all these
connections and the more words you know
the more things there are there that are
going to help you
link connect
and and and retain the meaning so that
that is certainly true so
at first you see these uh new words very
often because they're very high
frequency and as you keep learning of
course you're learning rarer and rarer
words but on the other hand you already
have so many words that it's easier it's
easier to learn them
um
i did uh let's see how much time i've
got left here i did a
discussion with my two grandchildren two
of my grandchildren who are in french
immersion and we talked about some of
the things that they do for language
learning and one of the things that
teachers do is is to get them to think
in terms of strategy
to learn french words so they get a
french sentence and the teacher decides
which are the difficult words and then
the student or the pupil here eight
years old has to write in the meaning of
that french word and then put a number
beside it number five if they identified
the meaning because of the picture
number four because of the
context number three because there was a
small word in the big word that helped
them
recognize the word number two was
because they knew it before and number
one was because it's similar to english
so they put a number
which i'm sure for the kids is fun but
i really wonder how
how useful it is to
get people to think in such a
self-conscious way
about their reading activity
my granddaughter said that when she
reads in french if she doesn't
understand she just continues reading
which is exactly what i do
if i'm reading away from the computer if
i can't look it up i don't understand it
i read on even if i have all the words
and i still can't make sense of it i
just read on and i i think there's a big
argument in favor of just letting people
read letting people listen letting
people get used to it look up words
review the words occasionally as a sort
of a stimulus as a massage for the brain
not necessarily because you're going to
nail those things down
and
to the extent that kids
identify words that are similar to
others or
infer the meaning from the context or
get it from the picture just let them do
that
why would you ask them to identify which
of these strategies they're using why
would you make them self-conscious about
how they are
enjoying their reading and how they're
deriving meaning from them from the
reading so i've had i've been on this
subject again and i guess i always come
back to this basic idea that if you can
enjoy what you're doing you will learn
and do whatever helps you enjoy
and
so
i've read lightner
uh
but i still think that what we're doing
at link uh makes a lot of sense but hey
everybody has their own different things
some people have other systems they use
there's anki out there there's
super memo and stuff whatever people
enjoy doing is great that was my more or
less review of lightner's book